yesterday on the view, the view is the daytime
talk show on [inaudible]
VC.
That is a really been a bigger and bigger
part of the 2020 election.
You've seen a lot of the democratic presidential
candidates stopped by.
Uh, you've seen Donald Trump talking about
the hosts.
They're part of the mill use, so to speak.
They talked about the Bernie Warren situation
in advance of yesterday's debate.
Of course, Bernie Sanders accused of telling,
uh, Elizabeth Warren that a woman can't win.
Bernie denied that during yesterday's debate
and everything went crazy.
And the, the disheartening thing is that they
basically on the view, accepted the story,
hook, line, and sinker without even questioning
the meeting of the meaning of what Bernie
is accused of saying.
So I've got a bunch of different clips to
play for you here.
Other than one example from joy Bay har, which
I will get to, this is how these stories spread.
CNN reports at Monday, the view talks about
it Tuesday basically not questioning the story.
CNN asks about it in their own debate Tuesday
night, and now it's a major story in the democratic
primary, which helps merely to prop up the
de facto establishment leader, which is Joe
Biden.
So first of all, let's go to the first clip
where they present as a foregone conclusion
that Bernie obviously said that a woman can't
win.
Warren conformed rumors that back in 2018
Bernie told her he doesn't think a women,
a woman could win the presidency.
Bernie denies it, saying he told her that,
you know, who has a sexist racist and he's
a lion.
He would weaponize anything he could, but
he does believe a woman could win.
Since Hillary beat, you know who by 3 million
votes last.
So is this going to be a talking point?
Is this more drama for the sake of Donald
Watts, the mom and dad and fighting Melissa
Warren was keeping this in her back pocket,
right?
She kept the receipts because I think they
made the pack when they got together in her
apartment saying, look, we have the same message.
We got to win this thing, so let's not tear
each other apart.
And then that happens.
And she's like, well fine, if you're going
to play the game that I'm going to play too.
So here Abby Huntsman presents it as a fair
tit for tat that Bernie did something and
Warren responded, but what did Bernie do?
We now know that indeed Bernie in some early
States deployed an anti Warren script attacking
Elizabeth Warren for appealing to highly educated
elites.
You can disagree with the strategy.
You can say, well, Bernie and Warren had agreed
not to do that.
And Bernie did it.
And that's between them.
But that's just normal politics accusing Bernie
of saying something if he didn't say it is
very different.
So, so equating that is a, is unfair and later
on, once again, that this idea of surrogates
a, a trashing Warren as equivalent,
I think they're, they're a bit different.
But what's interesting is that they did have
this pact and they had been friends for a
long time, but when she found out that his
surrogates were out there, as she said, trashing
her, she did come out and say, he doesn't
think a woman can win.
And I don't, he's denying it.
But I don't doubt that he perhaps set that.
I mean we've had 45 presidents, they've all
been men, right?
So he may very well think that, um, but rather
they'd rather vote for 78 year old socialist
who just had a heart attack than a woman,
I think.
I think, I think that that's is probably accurate,
but they've got to get together.
So now it's really a mess.
Sunny Hostin says, well, once Bernie trashed,
Warren Warren came out and said, Bernie said
a woman can't win.
Is that actually what happened?
And if so, does Sonny Hoston know about some
coordination between Elizabeth Warren and
CNN?
Because as far as the public facing narrative
goes, CNN ran the story Monday.
Warren was asked and confirmed it, but they
seem to be suggesting Bernie did a, so Warren
did B, is that actually the way it went down?
Because if Warren's involvement is that we
should know that that's very different than
the story that's being told.
Bernie is accused here of something that he
has denied by CNN and then Warren had the
opportunity to confirm or deny and she said,
yeah, that's the way it went down.
It's very coincidental timing right before
the debate on CNN.
So then incomes, joy Bay har with the, they
want to vote for a 78 year old socialists
who had a heart attack instead of a woman.
Again, reinforcing the idea of Bernie followers
as sexist.
Now at one point to her credit, joy Bay Harbor
does raise the point of is it sexist to point
out that sexism might prevent a woman from
winning, which I've now been saying for two
days.
Check that out.
I'd have to say, I don't see why this is big
news.
So two people are in a room because [inaudible]
finish my thought and then I'd love to hear
what you have to say.
But like, so people are in a room and they're
talking and one person says, gee, do you think
a woman can win the race in this country?
And the other one goes, I don't know about
that.
I mean, everybody has conversations like that.
Why is this a big story?
Well, it was made a big story by ignoring
that context.
Hey, if I say I doubted Jewish candidate can
win because of antisemitism and anti-Jewish
bias, uh, that might be true or it might be
wrong, but it's certainly not antisemitic.
If I say, I doubt a Muslim candidate can win
because of Islamophobia, okay, well we can
debate that, but it's not Islamophobic to
point that out saying, I doubt a woman can
win because of sexism and because of attitudes
towards women.
That is okay to say, and I'm glad joy Bay
heart brings it up.
Although it was not the context of the conversation
nor of the conversation during last night's
debate.
Then Megan McCain comes in and says, Hey,
I'm a Republican and sexism is bad, misogyny
is bad.
Trump sexism and misogyny are bad.
And I don't want another misogynist in the
oval office likening Donald Trump to Bernie,
which is mindblowingly crazy.
Take a look.
I'm sure I will have my Twitter just lit up
on fire because of this.
But he has a problem with women and he has
for a long time.
And I think if Elizabeth Warren has this in
her back pocket, all is fair in politics,
all's pair and love and war.
And I think, look, I don't want them another
misogynist as president.
Okay.
I mean, I think we're, all women in this country
are sick of it and I have always thought he
has had a problem with women.
Yeah.
We don't want Bernie because we already had
misogynist, sexist Trump.
And we don't want another one.
That's a crazy take.
I mean, that is just a straight up unhinge
take.
So again, this was the conclusion during our,
uh, debate analysis, and it once again is
the conclusion all of this narrative started
with the CNN article perpetuated by Elizabeth
Warren perpetuated yesterday on the view.
And then again last night during the debate
with CNN, literally after Bernie says, I didn't
say it, going to war, and, and saying, how
did you feel when Bernie said that?
Oh, he denied it.
Yeah.
We're not even going to mention that and asking
you the question.
It's a complete and total mess, which reinforces
the status quo, which is you've got an establishment
candidate, Joe Biden with a plurality of the
vote.
And the more this becomes a back and forth,
though, maybe Bernie loses a couple of points
here or gains a couple of points, or Warren
gains loses a couple.
It keeps Joe Biden at roughly 30% and in a
position where he is the most likely person
to secure the nomination.
That may have been the goal all along.